السعوديه عنوان عريض يحمل خلفه الكثير من
التساؤلات ومن العمل على تخفيفها وهذا ما
تحقق جزئيا بنهايه العام الماضي 2022 وفي
اخر ثلاثه اشهر او ما توصف اقتصاديا
بالربع الرابع من العام الماضي سجلت واحده
من ادنى معدلات البطاله حيث انخفضت الى
ثمانيه في المئه فقط هذا الرقم يعني اننا
اقتربنا كثيرا من الوصول الى مستهدف رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 لخفض البطاله بين السعوديين
الى سبعه في المئه مع تبقي ست سنوات وتسعه
اشهر مده طويله تبشر بتحقيق ارقام اعلى من
المستهدفات وحول معدل البطاله الاجمالي
الذي يشمل السعوديين وغير السعوديين فقد
انخفضت الى اربعه فاصله ثمانيه في المئه
ويشمل معدل البطاله الاجمالي المقيمين
الاجانب في المملكه الذين شكلوا ما يزيد
قليلا عن ثلث اجمالي السكان في عام 2021
ويحتاج معظمهم الى عقد عمل للعيش في
السعوديه
كيف يبحث العاطل عن عمل في السعوديه سؤال
الاقارب والاصدقاء اكثر اساليب البحث عن
عمل يليه التقدم المباشر لاصحاب العمل ثم
استخدام المنصات الوطنيه مثل جدارات التي
تشمل منصات اخرى مثل منصتي طاقات وساعد
هيئه الاحصاء السعوديه كشفت ايضا عن
استعداد اربعه وتسعين في المئه من
العاطلين للعمل في القطاع الخاص وان
غالبيه الباحثين عن عمل سيقبلون بالعمل
لاكثر من ثمان ساعات في اليوم هذه الارقام
مشاهدينا وغيرها تؤكد التوجه العام بين
اوصاد السعوديين للعمل في كل القطاعات وان
التفضيل العمل في القطاع الحكومي اصبح
شيئا من الماضي
وحول الخطوه التي تلي تحقيق مستهدفات رؤيه
السعوديه 2030 في خفض البطاله كدوليو
العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان في
لقائه الشهير في ابريل عام 2021 اكد
الانتقال الى مرحله تحسين الوظائف لا اقل
دخلا
والرغم هو مهم هل البطاله تزداد وتنخفض
لدينا البطاله انخفضت اذا قدرنا في نهايه
السنه هذه نخبه بطاله في خلال خمس سنوات
من رؤيه باربعه في المئه من 14% الى عشره
في المئه اربعه في المئه في اربع سنوات
معناتها 3%
سوف تكون قبل كثير من عشر
سنوات لكن ابغى اعطي رقم معين ومتى ما
وصلنا لسبعه في المئه سوف نبدا نعمل على
تحسين خطوه ثانيه اللي هو تحسين وظائف
ورفع دخل الخمسين في المئه الوظائفهم سيئه
من الرياض ينضم الينا وكيل وزاره الموارد
البشريه والتنميه البشريه للتوطين المهندس
ماجد الضحاوي سيد ماجد حياك الله معي في
نشره الرابعه رقم تاريخي رقم غير مسبوق
وتحقق بشكل سريع اقتربنا من تحقيق
المستهدف قبل تقريبا ست سنوات
نتحدث عن 7% معدل البطاله اريد ان اسال عن
الاسباب التي اوصلتنا الى هذا الرقم في
هذا الوقت من خلال وجهه نظر الوزاره وهي
احدى الجهه الفاعله في هذا الجان حياك
الله اخوي خالد امسي عليك وعلى الساده
المشاهدين ومبروك الشهر عليكم جميعا اولا
نبارك للجميع اصول هذا الرقم التاريخي
والغير مسبوق كما ذكرتم الى معدل بطاله
وصوله الى ثمانيه بالمئه وهذا طبعا ما تم
الا بدعم كبير وتمكين عالي من القياده
الرشيده ابرز ما المسببات لهذا النزول
اخوي خالد علي اذكر بعض منها
هو متانه الاقتصاد السعودي ونمو الحاصل في
الاقتصاد السعودي في عام 2022 حيث
الناتج المحلي في الاقتصاد السعودي
بنسبه 8.7
وهذه النسبه يعني اجتاز فيها دول العشرين
بشكل بشكل كبير كان الاكثر نموا بالنسبه
لدول العشرين هذه النسبه كانت كل التوقعات
منظمات الدوليه ترى انها اقصى نسبه ممكن
ان تكون ثمانيه فاصله ثلاثه من عشره ولذلك
لدينا اقتصاد ينمو بشكل بشكل فاعل دخول
السعوديين والسعوديات بشكل كبير الى سوق
العمل وتسجيل اكثر من اثنين مليون ومئتين
الف سعودي سعوديه ضمن التامينات
الاجتماعيه انعكس على هذا على سياسات
وزاره مواد البشريه وبرامج التوطين
والتعليم
والحقيقه مشاركه الجهات الحكوميه في تطوير
منظومه سوق العمل
للدخول هذه العدد من السعوديه للسعوديات
السوق يعني الامر يقتصر فقط على التوطين
ولا هناك العديد من الحزم من البرامج من
القرارات من المش دور كبير في الوصول الى
هذا الرقم الحقيقه
الانشطه والمهن النوعيه والمناطق واطلقت
ايضا برنامج نطاقات المطور ليحقق
مستهدفاته او تقريبا اوصل 92% من الثلاثه
سنوات ولكن دعم القطاع الخاص وتظافر
الجهات الحكوميه جميعا في هذه في هذا
القرارات دعم صندوق الموارد البشريه هدف
حيث دعم اكثر من 400 الف
باحثه باحثه في لدخول سوق العمل بميزانيه
تجاوزت الخمسه مليار كل هذه
الممكنات ساعدت على دخول السعوديين الى
سوق العمل جيد فيما يتعلق بالنساء او
السعوديات
الرقم المسجل اليوم ايضا هو رقم مهم
فبالتالي ما هي اهم ايضا القرارات
والمبادرات والبرامج اللي ساهمت في وصولها
الى هذا الرقم وتمكين المراه اليوم في سوق
العمل بهذا الشكل نعم الحقيقه نشهد مثل ما
ذكرتني القياسيه على كافه الاصل
نسبه مشاركه المراه كما تعلم زادت من 17
في 2015 2016 الى
تجاوزت مستهدف الرؤيه في عام 30 اللي هو
30% وصلت اليوم الى قرابه 37 بالمئه ايضا
انخفاض نسبه البطاله الى 15% لدى النساء
دليل على نجاح هذه السياسات من ابرز
الممكنات طبعا كل القرارات التوطين
اللي ذكرناها سابقا تشمل سواء السعوديات
والسعوديه لدخول سوق العمل وهي ممكن يحافز
كبير عملنا على عدد من البرامج التدريبيه
مثل البرنامج تدريب القيادي للقياديات
برنامج التدريب على راس العمل برامج كره
ووصول وهي برامج معنيه بالرعايه للاطفال
وضمان وصول السعوديات الى اعمالهم
بيسر وسهوله عبر يعني عدد من الحوافز اللي
تمكنهم من من الوصول الى اعمالهم او
يعني الحضانه للاطفال
هو هو هل انخفاض نسبه البطاله عند النساء
يعني ورفع نسبه العمل بالنسبه لهم خلال
السنوات القليله الماضيه من 17% للرقم
اللي تحقق اليوم هو السبب الرئيسي اليوم
في الوصول الى ثمانيه
الوصول الى هذا الرقم التاريخي وغير
المسبوق مهندس ماجد
نسبه البطاله
نوصل الى 4.8 اجباري نسبه البطاله لدى
السعوديين وصل الى 4.2 وايضا نسبه مشاركه
القوى العامله لدى السعوديين وصل الى
68% وهو ايضا رقم قياسي فنشهد ارقام
قياسيه على كافه
الاصعده ولا كافه المحاور للسعوديين
وللسعوديات زياده هذه المعدلات الخفضه
ايضا الارقام هذا يتطلب بالتاكيد جهود
كبيره ومتكامله وموحده من كثير من الجهات
الحكوميه او القطاع الخاص دكتور الى اي
مدى كان له دور في الوصول الى هذا الرقم
مقارنه بسنوات ماضيه
انا اعتقد الركيزه الاساسيه كانت تضافر
وتكامل الجهود الحكوميه لدى تحقيق هذا
المستهدف
اقتصاد ممكن وقطاع خاص ممكن وايضا لا ننسى
قدره وابناء وبنات الوطن الذي اثبتوا
الحقيقه في السنوات الماضيه قدرتهم على
الانخراط في سوق العمل
والعمل بكفاءه عاليه جدا يعطيكم العافيه
وشكرا جزيلا لك مره اخرى من الرياض وكيل
وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه للتوطين
المهندس ماجد شكرا لكم مهندس